you touched on something regarding the
99% and you say many writers can format
a script but most writers can't do and
that is yeah so in my experience as a
script consultant 99% of writers fail to
tell a story that what the 99% do
instead is I would describe as present a
situation so they pay me good money as a
script consultant to come in and read
their script it may be perfectly
formatted in industry standard it may
have some interesting characters here
and there may have some great dialogue
may have some interesting plot points
but invariably I was discovering 99% of
the time they were failing to tell a
story instead they were presenting a
situation so you know one way that I can
describe it a situation is it's like
life where in life this happens then
this happens then this happens and
that's not a story
right that's episodic a story there's a
connection where between the parts this
happens which leads to that happening
which makes it ironic when this other
thing happens there's a connection
between the parts another way I can put
it is if I can take your protagonist out
of your script and pull it a completely
different one in and maybe with a couple
of tweaks it works just as well
you have a situation my friend not a
story interesting I shouldn't be able to
do that if you're telling the story if I
were to take your protagonist out it
would no longer work a story is unique
to your protagonist there's something
there's a unique journey a reason why
you the master of the universe here has
put this character on this path there's
something in that character that you've
chosen to do this particular plot in
order to bring out something in them and
so if I can put just another character
in it works just as well that's not a
situation that's not testing anything
specific to the character it's just an
arbitrary situation that you put a
character you put someone into
and that's what most people do I mean
that's the way a lot of a start it's not
you know I don't mean to it doesn't mean
that it's not a fixable situation and
that's why my method is why I have these
on a forms that we can see visually
right there and then oh yeah this is
this piece is working but you can see
this piece doesn't work we can isolate
these elements and we can fix them
looking at this one-page form and it's
way easier to do it on this one-page
form then if you've already written a
screenplay then that's gonna be a bit
more of a mess we could still use the
form but it's gonna be it's gonna mean
going back a little bit to the drawing
board in order to fix those parts in
order to make it into a powerful story I
wonder if we can reverse engineer a
current film that's out and make it into
a situation so I know sometimes I use
movies that are dated so let me try to
like a star is born how could we reverse
engineer it so that if we broke it down
and we changed it to a situation so we
can see like dissect it let me give you
a different example sure my favorite
it's my favorite example is the movie
Tootsie oh that's right love so great
every screenwriter every filmmaker
should know Tootsie right if you haven't
saw you we have to go see it it's great
movie to look structurally this is what
it's exactly what's happening
99% of writers are writing what I call
fat tootsie okay
this is fat tootsie I'm gonna take the
same movie Tootsie we have a protagonist
Michael Dorsey out-of-work actor right
can't get an acting job and he's
desperate for an acting job and so he's
gonna audition for the soap opera and
I'm gonna make two very small changes to
the plot is he's got auditioned for the
soap opera in disguise but what it is
the part isn't a female character the
part is gonna be a male character but
the character is an obese man in the
fictional soap opera world and so for
the town that the soap opera takes place
in so Michael Dorsey is desperate for an
acting job right so he's gonna go to him
his makeup artist friend to have
prosthesis made and a costumer to make
him a fat suit and he's going to go into
the audition pretend
he's actually an obese man and he's
gonna get the part
so we have exact same movie Michael
Dorsey out-of-work actor desperate for
an acting job gets a part on a soap
opera the only thing I'm gonna change is
instead of the part being a female
character it's a part of a fat man right
very similar movie almost works right we
tend to think it's funny seeing a man
dressed up as a woman in movies we also
could find it funny seeing this little
you know guy like Dustin Hoffman
pretending to be a big fat guy right
he's got to get in out of his fat suit
you know before anyone sees him it
almost works but ultimately fat twit C
is a situation not a story you have any
idea what the difference might be I'm
trying to forgive me it's been a it's
been a little bit since I've seen it I'm
just remembering like when he is to see
that you know there's like this sort of
where someone falls in love with him and
there's this like dilemma like how do
like you know how does he tell him that
he's a man he can he's got to keep this
covered so what would be yeah and I
could even tweak it though when that
wasn't an issue we're in in it he gets a
crush on his female costar
right I'll make another tweak though for
fat okay he'll tell his co-star
that he's gay so fact so she Theodore
Lee the love interest feels just as
comfortable with him her co-star who she
perceives as this gay fat man right she
feels just as comfortable with him as
she felt with the Dorothy character the
female persona so still almost works
right we have the exact same thing and
then for the love interest because he's
he says he's gay part of the real in the
movie the tinted see that his Julie's
father gets a crush on the Dorothy
character Rob will make will make
Julie's father gay right so that could
work so it's still working the same you
stumped me yeah I'm I want to get I some
this is the key
this is key and let me tell you 99% of
writers are writing fat Twitty it's a
clever sounding situation but it's not a
story the key the big difference is one
of the biggest structural this is one of
the eight elements but it's the most
important element is the flaw that
there's something in this journey that
you've chosen in the plot you've created
that you put this character in that's
gonna test a central flaw in them any
idea what Michel Dorsey's flaw might be
well I guess he's he's struggling with
his career yeah it's true yeah but if
lost something we can blame them went
for so something look at them you look
down upon them so what would you say is
what is a negative about him that we're
judging we can judge him about your kind
in the ballpark though it has it's
related to its career all right lack of
confidence lack of skill maybe he's not
a Honi I don't know going out parts he
has a different overinflated a view of
himself
under-inflated I don't know well I think
most people point out the overinflated
view that he's very very arrogant right
that he is that's you know one of the
reasons he hasn't been getting acting
work is because he's so difficult to
work with
the only thing is I would argue after
the movie Trixie do you think this guy
is gonna be any less arrogant on his
next acting job no because he was able
to pull it off right and so now he has
exactly yeah exactly so that hasn't yes
that is one of his flaws arrogance it's
not the one that the movies testing the
one that the movies testing is his lack
of respect for women ah
okay right so we've seen the beginning
this early scene at this party he hits
on every single woman with the same
stupid line right even though I think
he'd probably call himself a feminist
he's actually a real jerk to women right
he's good he's great friends with the
Teri Garr character and but the moment
they sleep together
he suddenly freaks out and shrieks
treats her terribly so deep down he is
this lack of respect for women that is
the perfect test of somebody who has a
lack of respect for women if you make
them happy
to pretend to be a woman interesting
right but in fact to see that has
nothing to do with this flaw it's an
arbitrary situation we put him in so
unless we were to change the flaw
we made the flaw you know somebody who
had a prejudice against people you know
of different weight or different
appearance something like that we could
do we could we could change the
character so it was testing someone but
with the character that's in the
original tutsi of this man who was
arrogant and doesn't respect women
putting them in a fat suit that doesn't
do anything to test that character right
so that's what 99% of writers are doing
it sounds clever right sounds
interesting to see somebody you know
he's trying to pretend it seems to be
has some interesting themes about being
someone who trying to pretend to be
someone who you're not we've got some
funny comedy moments ideas in there it
has nothing to do with the character
right and he gets hit on and I remember
the one scene where they're like can you
guys back up the camera like how far can
we go so he's being judged for his looks
being hit on all these different things
I'll be seeing right right right he does
even in the movie in the in in Cocke you
know in that second act he still doesn't
realize it you know that he's been doing
these things all along and it's it's
there's a great moment where the sexist
director turns things around and says
something what about the fact that that
you know he's the sexist director has
been dating Julie and the his Michael's
Dorothy persona it's kind of suggest I
know what's going on and and the
director says yeah yeah you know yeah
sure I see other women but I wouldn't
want to tell her I wouldn't want to hurt
her right and Mike endorsees used that
exact same line talking about Teri Garr
right of course you know I don't want to
hurt her right so he doesn't even
realize he's doing these things
sure so this is the way this is the way
we're gonna get the character to finally
face something so another important
concept about this is that your
characters not a victim Michael Dorsey
is not a victim of the universe suddenly
making him have to be a woman and deal
with that he actually asked for this he
wanted an acting part he said he could
handle
he said I'll take you know I'll do
anything I'll do any acting job he
willingly went in there an audition for
this so this is another part of the 99%
they're making their character a victim
of circumstance they're having arbitrary
stuff happen to the character it
shouldn't be your character should not
be a victim even if your character is a
victim for them truly to be a
protagonist then you have a certain
amount of agency involved they need to
be contributing to the problem in some
way if you don't give your character a
strong flaw
you're just making them a victim the
reason these bad things are happening to
them they're just faked it's just bad
luck in the world it shouldn't be that
that might be part of it but it needs to
be part of you know why it's so
difficult for Michael Dorsey and Tootsie
is the fact that he's sexist if he were
a sexist guy he wouldn't have been
having a difficult time in act 2 of
Tootsie so what we're doing is that
we're making sure that we're testing the
character with something that is getting
something getting down something deep
down inside of them that's unique to
them and that's why this character
exists in this story instead of another
character
you